kyle hendricks leading the boys out onto
the field 14-6 record despite that uh
career-high era of 4.81 brent rooker
and hits that oh nice play frank
[Applause]
he's been working hard on his defense i
mean out there just about every day
and then yeah the point into the dugout
yeah all this hard work's paying off so
two down and here comes josh donaldson
and donaldson continues to swing a good
bat our ground ball single up the middle
i'm going to bring out max kepler now
max also had a good night last night he
snapped an old for 18 with a three hit
night fly ball into right center field
deep this one's back towards the
bleachers and gone wind or no win kepler
with a rocket to right center field a
two out two run homer and the twins took
a two-nothing lead congratulations he
needed that one more home run he tied
eddie rosario now
119
career home runs 15th all-time in twins
history joe ryan making his fourth start
of the season he's going to use his
fastball to get ahead of the hitters and
get them out the 1-2 swag and a miss and
downey goes and a fastball at 93.
strikeout number 15 for ryan two bases
empty for frank schwendell
two strikeouts for ryan and now it'll be
patrick wisdom one two count two nothing
twins and the pitch right down the
middle at 92 strike three taken and ryan
comes out dominates the first inning and
strikes out the side two nothing twins
second inning here's matt duffy
that one sliced the other way and that's
a fair ball
half racing towards third
willy harris going to hold him up and
they're at second and third so the cubs
with a threat with nobody out and there
you have it matt duffy able to slice one
into the right field corner happen third
duffy at second nico one for three last
night let's see if he can lash out a
game tying base hit line drive base hit
center field one run is in duffy around
third he'll head home the throw by
gordon cut off two run single nikko
horner ball game tied two to two
but it's an absolute bullet off the bat
of corner great swing and that's what
you're looking for and he ties up the
ball rafaela ortega two two game one out
bottom three
breaking ball first strike he's gotten
with it and it's strike three two down
the batteries frank schwendell
line towards shallow left center in
there for a base hit
schwendell a bloop single kept the hands
back nicely on a slow curve 11-game
hitting streak for frank
here's the 2-2 swag and a miss he struck
him out in a fastball so ryan has fanned
five through two
and here's kepler difference maker right
now with that
two-run homer his 18th to the year
deep to right field and kepler has
another one and the twins are back in
front kepler with two home runs in his
first two at bats
and the twins take a 3-2 lead
was able to drive their ball for a
second homer tonight very good hit pitch
count at 54 for
ryan
came back to get him and not
overpowering him with velocity but
perceived velocity which is something
joe ryan definitely has ryan will be
dealing five strikeouts in three innings
there's a breaking ball strike three 81
on the slider
so back to back strikeouts strikeout
number seven and here's robinson torinos
and fastball buzzed at the knees three
strikeouts again in a one two three four
facing ryan who in his big league career
two-thirds of his innings at this level
have been one two three in it there's a
pitch called for a strike four five
straight strikeouts now for ryan and the
last six outs have come on strikeout
three balls two strikes
at the knees on the corner beautiful
pitch
by ryan strikeout number 10. two down
pitcher spot and kyle hendricks will bat
and the pitch
strike three looking hendricks knew it
that is seven strikeouts in a row the
last four have all been looking three up
three down through five here is the
mighty casey max kepler two-run homer in
the first the fourth inning crushed it
a drive right field deep to right center
max kepler is off the wall missing a
home run by a matter of feet and he will
stand at second after nearly hitting his
third home run for the third time in his
career chess miss hitting his third
straight homing off for kyle hendricks
the ball landed
bounced off the hefty sign in right
center field well here's jeno has a
chance
rolls one through the legs of duffy
kepler around third and he'll score
should have been the third out but duffy
didn't field it
no run batted in for sano but it's four
to two simmons with two groundouts in
his return to the lineup
simmons
drives one
softly into the gap in right center his
first hit and it looks like byron buxton
will grab a bat and step in here
softly into left center and that'll flop
in there for a hit simmons got a real
good read on that ball and now buxton
slides into second how about that
sometimes you'll see it on artificial
turf a ball like that infamously dan
gladden in game seven of the 91 world
series taking the extra base because of
the high hop but this one landed and
hardly bounced at all and buxton still
got a double out of it and the 2-2 swing
of the miss strike three there's the
high fastball that you talked about and
it gets the job done jake cave batting
for the first time
so i'm doing we really appreciate you
folks yes
a guy sitting down with a glove that's
what i'm talking about
and he's got soccer first baseman's
glove yes
i mean look at watch him look at mr
stoic bang
yeah
through a screen stretch
roll the replays
and the one-two pitch on the way to cave
swinging a miss strike three as the
light gets out of the jam twins don't
score they lead the cubs four to two
gordon stated third base so one out
and simmons punches one to right field
fairly deep thompson with the catch
gordon will tag head home the throw to
the plate will be late so simmons with a
sac fly to right so gordon speed pays
off two down base is empty in the ninth
inning but the twins now take a 5-2 lead
frank schwendel leads off the bottom of
the ninth and cubs trail 5-2
[Music]
drilled out towards left center and
that'll touch down for a hit this guy's
unreal i mean it's just
the amount of time between rockets
is
really limited yeah yeah the softie
first his first [ __ ] of the game but
this is a cutter right in the middle of
the strike zone at 91 and he barrels it
up
one away here is ian happ and they've
managed five hits they need some more to
win this game the 0-1
there's a liner in the left center
that's going to be a base hit
cut off by cave coming in to score
schwendell
rbi single ian a half it's a five to
three ball game he gets this ball away
and hammers this ball into the gap oh he
walked in ball four and now the tying
run is on and the winning run is coming
up in contreras the runners go the pitch
swinging a miss but it's a double steal
and the cubs have men at second and
third
chopper
donaldson will get the out
high throw sono with the tag that'll be
challenged i can guarantee you that but
right now contreras is out at second
base
comes a look at it yeah you can see the
flop of ceno's glove when contact out
call should stand second run has scored
here in the ninth and out is the call so
the winning run at second base the tying
run at third five four twins bottom nine
trace thompson tonight is all for
and the 0.2 pitch swag and a miss he
struck him out and that's the game as
thompson chased a cutter in the dirt
and the twins survive and sweep the
two-game series
you